traditional animation like traditional
filmmaking has historically has a linear
development we say okay you go muybridge
you go muybridge to black then blacked
into John Randall Bray to Walt Disney to
the studios and and Hollywood and and
it's like you follow this track while CG
you have sort of like the government you
know military flight simulators and you
have academia like MIT and Utah and
Stanford and then you have motion
picture visual effects and you have
games people building games like in you
know at em like at MIT they build a
thing called Space wars in 1962 which is
like the first interactive game and and
all of these are all on separate tracks
it said I resided like plotlines in a
Russian novel you kind of like the kind
of thing you know they're all they're
all on their own and then they all start
to congeal start to come together around
the 1980s but that's a lot of the beauty
of it I think that's a lot of what made
this unique is that we're in most
traditions whether it's the art
tradition the film tradition perhaps
things are very linear in that way but
what was fascinating here was he had
this whole different group of people who
are interested in the creativity of it
all yeah they were exploring new
territory that's not that same year 1975
I went cross-country and tried to find
everybody I could find it was doing
anything that involved making pictures
with computers and as a result I wound
up talking everybody you know physicists
astrophysicists programmers you name it
and that was a wonderful realization
that people coming from these different
disciplines were all headed towards the
same target because it was something new
you